[Music]
when the time for his examination drew
near
malcolm malcolmson made up his mind to
go somewhere to read by himself
he feared the attractions of the seaside
and also he feared completely rural
isolation
for of old he knew its charms and so he
determined to find some unpretentious
little town where there would be nothing
to distract him
he refrained from asking suggestions
from any of his friends
for he argued that each would recommend
some place of which he had knowledge
and where he had already acquaintances
as malcolmson wished to avoid friends
he had no wish to encumber himself with
the attention of friend's friends
and so he determined to look out for a
place for himself
he packed to portmanteau with some
clothes and all the books he required
and then took ticket for the first name
on the local timetable which he did
not know when at the end of three hours
journey he alighted at ben
church he felt satisfied that he had so
far
obliterated his tracks as to be sure of
having a peaceful opportunity of
pursuing his studies
he went straight to the one in which the
sleepy little place contained
and put up for the night ben church was
a market town
and once in three weeks was crowded to
excess but for the remainder of the 21
days
it was as attractive as a desert
malcolmson looked around the day after
his arrival
to try to find quarters more isolated
than even so quiet and
in as the good traveler afforded there
was only one place which took his fancy
and it certainly satisfied his wildest
ideas regarding quiet
in fact quiet was not the proper word to
apply to it
desolation was the only term conveying
any suitable idea of its isolation
it was an old rambling heavy-built house
of the jacobean style
with heavy gables and windows unusually
small
and set higher than was customary in
such houses
and was surrounded with a high brick
wall massively built
indeed on examination it looked more
like a fortified house than an ordinary
dwelling
but all these things pleased malcolmson
here he thought
is the very spot i have been looking for
and if i can only get an opportunity of
using it i shall be happy
his joy was increased when he realized
beyond doubt that it was not at present
inhabited
from the post office he got the name of
the agent who was rarely surprised at
the application to rent a part of the
old house
mr carnford the local lawyer and agent
was a genial old gentleman
and frankly confessed his delight at
anyone being willing to live in the
house
to tell you the truth said he i should
be only too happy
on behalf of the owners to let anyone
have the house rent free
for a term of years if only to accustom
the people here to see it inhabited
it has been so long empty that some kind
of absurd prejudice has grown up about
it
and this can be best put down by its
occupation
if only he added with a sly glance at
malcomson
by a scholar like yourself who wants
it's quiet for a time
malcolmson thought it needless to ask
the agent about the absurd prejudice
he knew he would get more information if
he should require it on that subject
from other quarters
he paid his three months rent got a
receipt and the name of an old woman who
would probably undertake to do for him
and came away with the keys in his
pocket he then went to the landlady of
the inn
who was a cheerful and most kindly
person and asked her advice
as to such stores and provisions as he
would be likely to require
she threw up her hands in amazement when
he told her where he was going
to settle himself not in the judge's
house
she said and grew pale as she spoke he
explained the locality of the house
saying that he did not know its name
when he had finished
she answered aye sure enough sure enough
the very place
it is the judge's house sure enough he
asked her to tell him about the place
why so called and what there was against
it
she told him that it was so called
locally because it had been many years
before
how long she could not say as she was
herself from another part of the country
but she thought it must have been a
hundred years or more the abode of a
judge who was held in great terror on
account of his harsh sentences
and his hostility to prisoners at a
sizes
as to what there was against the house
she could not tell
she had often asked but no one would
inform her
but there was a general feeling that
there was something
and for her own part she would not take
all the money in drinkwater's bank to
stay in the house an hour by herself
then she apologized to malcomson for her
disturbing talk
it is too bad of me sir and you and a
young gentleman too
if you will pardon me saying it going to
live there all alone
if you were my boy and you'll excuse me
for saying it
you wouldn't sleep there a night not if
i had to go there myself and pull the
big alarm bell that's on the roof
the good creature was so manifestly in
earnest and was so kindly in her
intentions
that malcolmson although amused was
touched
he told her kindly how much he
appreciated her interest in him
and added but my dear mrs witham indeed
you need not be concerned about me
a man who is reading for the
mathematical tripos has too much to
think of to be disturbed by any of these
mysterious somethings
and his work is of too exact and
prosaica kind
to allow if his having any order in his
mind for mysteries of any kind
harmonical progression permutations and
combinations
and elliptic functions have sufficient
mysteries for me
mrs whitham kindly undertook to see
after his commissions
and he went himself to look for the old
woman who had been recommended to him
when he turned to the judge's house with
her after an interval of a couple of
hours
he found mrs whitham herself waiting
with several men and boys carrying
parcels
and an upholsterer's man with a bed and
a cart
four she said though table and chairs
might all be very well
a bed that hadn't been aired in maybe 50
years was not proper for young ones to
lie on
she was evidently curious to see the
inside of the house
and though manifestly so afraid of the
somethings that at the slightest sound
she clutched onto malcolmson
whom she never left for a moment went
over the whole place
after his examination of the house
malcolmson decided to take up his abode
in the great dining room
which was big enough to serve for all
his requirements and mrs witham with the
aid of the char woman mrs dempster
proceeded to arrange matters when the
hampers were brought in and unpacked
malcolmson saw
that with much kind forethought she had
sent from her own kitchen
sufficient provisions to last for a few
days
before going she expressed all sorts of
kind wishes
and at the door turned and said and
perhaps sir
as the room is big and drafty it might
be well to have one of those big screens
put round your bed at night
though truth to tell i would die myself
if i were to be so
shut in with all kinds of of things that
put their heads around the sides are
over the top
and look on me the image which she had
called up was too much for her nerves
and she fled incontinently
mrs dempster sniffed in a superior
manner as the landlady disappeared
and remarked that for her own part she
wasn't afraid of all the bogeys in the
kingdom
i'll tell you what it is sir she said
bogeys is all kinds and sorts of things
except bogeys rats and mice and beetles
and creaky doors
and loose slates and broken panes and
stiff drawer handles that stay out when
you pull them and then fall down in the
middle of the night
look at the wainscot of the room it is
old hundreds of years old
do you think there's no rats and beetles
there and do you imagine sir that you
won't see none of them
rats is bogeys i tell you and bogeys is
rats and don't you get to think anything
else
mrs dempster said malcolm son gravely
making her a polite bow
you know more than a senior wrangler and
let me say
that as a mark of esteem for your
indubitable soundness of head and heart
i shall when i go give you possession of
this house
and let you stay here by yourself for
the last two months of my tenancy
for four weeks will serve my purpose
thank you kindly sir she answered but i
couldn't sleep away from home a night
i am in greenhouse charity and if i
slept a night away from my rooms i
should lose all i've got to live on the
rules is very strict and there's too
many watching for a vacancy for me to
run any risks in the matter
only for that sir i'd gladly come here
and attend on you all together during
your stay
my good woman said malcomson hastily i
have come here on a purpose to obtain
solitude and believe me that i am
grateful to the late greenhouse for
having organized his admirable charity
whatever it is that i am perforced
denied the opportunity of suffering from
such a form of temptation
saint anthony himself could not be more
rigid on the point
the old woman laughed harshly ah you
young gentleman
she said you don't fear for naught and
be like you'll get all the solitude you
want here
she set to work with her cleaning and by
nightfall when malcomson returned from
his walk
he always had one of his books to study
as he walked he found the room swept and
tidied
a fire burning on the old hearth the
lamp lit
and the table spread for supper with mrs
whitham's excellent
fare this is comfort indeed he said
and rubbed his hands when he had
finished his supper and lifted the tray
to the other end of the great oak dining
table
he got out his books again put fresh
wood on the fire trimmed his lamp
and set himself down to a spell of real
hard work
he went on without a pause till about
eleven o'clock when he knocked off for a
bit
to fix his fire and lamp and to make
himself a cup of tea
he had always been a tea drinker and
during his college life had sat late at
work
and had taken tea late the rest was a
great luxury to him
and he enjoyed it with a sense of
delicious voluptuous ease
the renewed fire leaped and sparkled and
threw quaint shadows through the great
old room
and as he sipped his hot tea he reveled
in the sense of isolation from his kind
then it was that he began to notice for
the first time
what a noise the rats were making surely
he thought they cannot have been added
all the time i was reading
had they been i must have noticed it
presently when the noise increased he
satisfied himself that it was really new
it was evident that at first the rats
had been frightened at the presence of a
stranger
and the light of fire and lamp but that
as the time went on they had grown
bolder and were now disporting
themselves as was their want
how busy they were and hark to the
strange noises
up and down the old wainscot over the
ceiling and under the floor they raced
and gnawed and scratched malcolmson
smiled to himself
as he recalled to mind the saying of mrs
dempster bogeys as rats and rats as
bogeys
the tea began to have its effect of
intellectual and nervous stimulus
he saw with joy and other long spell of
work to be done before the night was
passed
and in the sense of security which it
gave him he allowed himself the luxury
of a good look around the room
he took his lamp in one hand and went
all round
wondering that so quaint and beautiful
an old house had been so long neglected
the carving of the oak on the panels of
the wainscot was fine and on and round
the doors and windows it was beautiful
and of rare merit there were some old
pictures on the walls
but they were coated so thick with dust
and dirt that he could not distinguish
any detail of them
though he held his lamp as high as he
could over his head
here and there as he went round he saw
some crack or hole
blocked for a moment by the face of a
rat with its bright eyes glittering in
the light
but in an instant it was gone and a
squeak and a scamper followed
the thing that most struck him however
was the rope of the great alarm bell on
the roof
which hung down in a corner of the room
on the right-hand side of the fireplace
he pulled up close to the hearth a great
high-backed carved oak chair
and sat down to his last cup of tea when
this was done
he made up the fire and went back to his
work sitting at the corner of the table
having the fire to his left for a little
while the rats disturbed him somewhat
with their perpetual scampering
but he got accustomed to the noise as
one does to the ticking of the clock or
to the roar of moving water
and he became so immersed in his work
that everything in the world
except the problem which he was trying
to solve passed away from him
he suddenly looked up his problem was
still unsolved
and there was in the air that sense of
the hour before the dawn
which is so dread to doubtful life the
noise of the rats had ceased
indeed it seemed to him that it must
have ceased but lately
and that it was the sudden cessation
which had disturbed him
the fire had fallen low but still it
threw out a deep red glow
as he looked he started in spite of his
zhang foie
there on the great high-backed carved
oak chair by the right side of the
fireplace
sat an enormous rat steadily glaring at
him with baleful eyes
he made a motion to it as though to hunt
it away but it did not stir
then he made the motion of throwing
something still
it did not stir but showed its great
white teeth angrily
and its cruel eyes shone in the
lamplight with an added vindictiveness
malcolmson felt amazed and seizing the
poker from the hearth ran
at it to kill it before however he could
strike it
the rat with a squeak that sounded like
the concentration of hate
jumped upon the floor and running up the
rope of the alarm bell
disappeared in the darkness beyond the
range of the green shaded lamp
instantly strange to say the noisy
scampering of the rats in the wainscot
began again
by this time malcolmson's mind was quite
off the problem
and as a shrill cockcrow outside told
him of the approach of mourning
he went to bed and to sleep he slept so
sound that he was not even waked by mrs
dempster coming in to make up his room
it was only when she had tidied up the
place and got his breakfast ready and
tapped on the screen which closed in his
bed
that he woke he was a little tired still
after his night's hard work but a strong
cup of tea
soon freshened him up and taking his
book he went out for his morning walk
bringing with him a few sandwiches lest
he should not care to return till dinner
time
he found a quiet walk between high elms
some way outside the town
and here he spent the greater part of
the day studying his laplace
on his return he looked in to see mrs
witham and to thank her for her kindness
when she saw him coming through the
diamond-paned bay window of her sanctum
she came out to meet him and asked him
in she looked at him searchingly
and shook her head as she said you must
not overdo it sir
you are paler this morning than you
should be two late hours and two hard
work on the brains isn't good for any
man
but tell me sir how did you pass the
night well i hope
but my heart sir i was glad when mrs
dempster told me this morning that you
were all right
and sleeping sound when she went in oh i
was all right
he answered smiling the somethings
didn't worry me
as yet only the rats and they had a
circus i tell you
all over the place there was one wicked
looking old devil that sat up on my own
chair by the fire
and wouldn't go till i took the poker to
him and then he ran up the rope of the
alarm bell
and got to somewhere up the wall or the
ceiling i couldn't see where it was so
dark
mercy on us said mrs witham an old devil
and sitting on a chair by the fireside
take care sir
take care there's many a true word
spoken in jest
how do you mean upon my word i don't
understand
an old devil the old devil perhaps
there sir you needn't laugh for
malcolmson had broken into a hearty peel
you young folks think it easy to laugh
at things that makes older ones shudder
never mind sir never mind please god
you'll laugh all the time
it's what i wish you myself and the good
lady beamed all over in sympathy with
his enjoyment
her fear is gone for a moment oh forgive
me
said malcolmson presently don't think me
rude but the idea was too much for me
that the old devil himself was on the
chair last night
and at the thought he laughed again then
he went home to dinner
this evening the scampering of the rats
began earlier
indeed it had been going on before his
arrival and only ceased while his
presence by its freshness disturbed them
after dinner he sat by the fire for a
while and had a smoke
and then having cleared his table began
to work as before
tonight the rats disturbed him more than
they had done on the previous night
how they scampered up and down and under
and over
how they squeaked and scratched and
gnawed how they
getting bolder by degrees came to the
mouths of their holes and to the chinks
and cracks and crannies and the
wainscoting
till their eyes shone like tiny lamps as
the fire light rose and fell
but to him now doubtless accustomed to
them their eyes were not wicked
only their playfulness touched him
sometimes the boldest of them made
sally's out on the floor
or along the moldings of the wainscot
now and again as they disturbed him
malcolmson made a sound to frighten them
smiting the table with his hand
or giving a fierce so that they fled
straight away to their holes
and so the early part of the night wore
on and despite the noise malcolmson got
more and more immersed in his work
all at once he stopped as on the
previous night being overcome by a
sudden silence
it was not the faintest sound of gnaw or
scratch or squeak
the silence was as of the grave he
remembered the odd occurrence of the
previous night
and instinctively he looked at the chair
standing close by the fireside
and then a very odd sensation thrilled
through him
there on the great old high-backed
carved oak chair beside the fireplace
sat the same enormous rat steadily
glaring at him with baleful
eyes instinctively he took the nearest
thing to his hand
a book of logarithms and flung it at it
the book was badly aimed and the rat did
not stir
so again the poker performance of the
previous night was repeated
and again the rat being closely pursued
fled up the rope of the alarm bell
strangely too the departure of this rat
was instantly followed by the renewal of
the noise made by the general rat
community
on this occasion as on the previous one
malcolmson could not see at what part of
the room the rat disappeared
for the green shade of his lamp left the
upper part of the room in darkness
and the fire had burned low on looking
at his watch he found it was close on
midnight
and not sorry for the divertis ma he
made up his fire and made himself his
nightly pot of tea
he had got through a good spell of work
and thought himself entitled to a
cigarette
and so he sat on the great carved oak
chair before the fire and enjoyed it
whilst smoking he began to think that he
would like to know where the rat
disappeared to
for he had certain ideas for the morrow
not entirely disconnected with a rat
trap
accordingly he lit another lamp and
placed it so that it would shine well
into the right-hand corner of the wall
by the fireplace
then he got all the books he had with
him and placed them handy to throw at
the vermin
finally he lifted the rope of the alarm
bell and placed the end of it on the
table
fixing the extreme end under the lamp as
he handled it he could not help noticing
how
pliable it was especially for so strong
a rope and one not in use
you could hang a man with it he thought
to himself
when his preparations were made he
looked around and said
complacently there now my friend i think
we shall learn something of you this
time
he began his work again and though as
before somewhat disturbed at first by
the noise of the rats
soon lost himself in his proposition and
problems
again he was called to his immediate
surroundings suddenly
this time it might not have been the
sudden silence only which took his
attention
there was a slight movement of the rope
and the lamp moved
without stirring he looked to see if his
pile of books was within range
and then cast his eye along the rope as
he looked he saw the great rat
drop from the rope on the oak armchair
and sit there glaring at him he raised a
book in his right hand
and taking careful aim flung it at the
rat
the latter with a quick movement sprang
aside and dodged the missile
then he took another book and a third
and flung them one after the other at
the rat
but each time unsuccessfully at last
as he stood with a book poised in his
hand to throw the rat squeaked and
seemed afraid
this made malcolmson more than ever
eager to strike and the book flew and
struck the rat a resounding blow
it gave a terrified squeak and turning
on his pursuer a look of terrible
malevolence
ran up the chair back and made a great
jump to the rope of the alarm bell
and ran up it like lightning the lamp
rocked under the sudden strain
but it was a heavy one and did not
topple over
malcolmson kept his eyes on the rat and
saw it by the light of the second lamp
leap to a molding of the wainscot and
disappear through a hole in one of the
great pictures which hung on the wall
obscured and invisible through its
coating of dirt and dust
i shall look up my friend's habitation
in the morning said the student
as he went over to collect his books the
third picture from the fireplace
i shall not forget he picked up the
books one by one
commenting on them as he lifted them
conic sections
he does not mind nor cycloid isolations
nor the principia nor quaternions nor
thermodynamics
now for a look at the book that fetched
him
malcolmson took it up and looked at it
as he did so he started
and a sudden pallor overspread his face
he looked round uneasily and shivered
slightly as he murmured to himself
the bible my mother gave me what an odd
coincidence
he sat down to work again and the rats
in the wainscot renewed their gambles
they did not disturb him however somehow
their presence gave him a sense of
companionship
but he could not attend to his work and
after striving to master the subject on
which he was engaged
gave it up in despair and went to bed as
the first streak of dawn stole in
through the eastern window
he slept heavily but uneasily and
dreamed much
and when mrs dempster woke him late in
the morning he seemed ill at ease
and for a few minutes did not seem to
realize exactly where he was
his first request rather surprised the
servant
mrs dempster when i am out today i wish
he would get the steps and dust or wash
those pictures
especially that one the third from the
fireplace i want to see what they are
late in the afternoon malcolmson worked
at his books in the shaded walk
and the cheerfulness of the previous day
came back to him as the day wore on
and he found that his reading was
progressing well
he had worked out to a satisfactory
conclusion all the problems which had
has yet baffled him
and it was in a state of jubilation that
he paid a visit to mrs witham at the
good traveler
he found a stranger in the cozy sitting
room with the landlady
who was introduced to him as dr
thornhill
she was not quite at ease and this
combined with the doctors plunging it
once into a series of questions
made malcolmson come to the conclusion
that his presence was not an accident
so without preliminary he said dr
thornhill
i shall with pleasure answer you any
question you may choose to ask me
if you will answer me one question first
the doctor seemed surprised but he
smiled and answered it once
done what is it did mrs whitham ask you
to come here and see me
and advise me dr thornhill for a moment
was taken aback
and mrs witham got fiery red and turned
away
but the doctor was a frank and ready man
and he answered it once and openly
she did but she didn't intend you to
know it i suppose it was my clumsy haste
that made you suspect
she told me that she did not like the
idea of your being in that house all by
yourself
and that she thought you took too much
strong tea
in fact she wants me to advise you if
possible to give up the tea
and the very late hours i was a keen
student in my time
so i suppose i may take the liberty of a
college man
and without offense advise you not quite
as a stranger
malcolmson with a bright smile held out
his hand
shake as they say in america he said i
must thank you for your kindness
and mrs withem too and your kindness
deserves a return on my
part i promise to take no more strong
tea
no tea at all till you let me and i
shall go to bed tonight at one o'clock
at the latest
will that do capital said the doctor
now tell us all that you noticed in the
old house
and so malcolmson then and there told in
my new detail
all that had happened in the last two
nights he was interrupted every now and
then by some exclamation from mrs witham
till finally when he told of the episode
of the bible the landlady's pent-up
emotions found vent in a shriek
and it was not till a stiff glass of
brandy and water had been administered
that she grew composed again dr
thornhill listened with a face of
growing gravity
and when the narrative was complete and
mrs whitham had been restored
he asked the rat always went up the rope
of the alarm bell
always i suppose you know
said the doctor after a pause what that
rope is
no it is so the doctor slowly
the very rope which the hangman used for
all the victims of the judge's judicial
ranker
here he was interrupted by another
scream from mrs witham
and steps had to be taken for her
recovery
malcolmson having looked at his watch
and found that it was close to his
dinner hour
had gone home before her complete
recovery
when mrs whitham was herself again she
almost assailed the doctor with angry
questions
as to what he meant by putting such
horrible ideas into the poor young man's
mind
he has quite enough there already to
upset him she added
dr thornhill replied my dear madam i had
a distinct purpose in it
i wanted to draw his attention to the
bell rope and to fix it there
it may be that he is in a highly
overwrought state and has been studying
too much
although i am bound to say that he seems
as sound and healthy a young man
mentally and bodily as ever i saw but
then the rats
and that suggestion of the devil the
doctor shook his head and went on
i would have offered to go and stay the
first night with him but that i felt
sure it would have been a cause of
offense
he may get in the night some strange
fright or hallucination
and if he does i want him to pull that
rope all alone as he is it will give us
a warning
and we may reach him in time to be of
service i shall be sitting up pretty
late tonight and she'll keep my ears
open
do not be alarmed if ben church gets a
surprise before morning
oh doctor what do you mean what do you
mean
i mean this that possibly nay more
probably
we shall hear the great alarm bell from
the judge's house tonight
and the doctor made about an effective
an exit as could be thought of
when malcolmson arrived home he found
that it was a little after his usual
time
and mrs dempster had gone away the rules
of greenhouse charity were not to be
neglected
he was glad to see that the place was
bright and tidy with a cheerful fire and
a well-trimmed lamp
the evening was colder than might have
been expected in april
and a heavy wind was blowing with such
rapidly increasing strength
that there was every promise of a storm
during the night
for a few minutes after his entrance the
noise of the rats ceased
but so soon as they became accustomed to
his presence they began again
he was glad to hear them for he felt
once more the feeling of companionship
in their noise
and his mind ran back to the strange
fact that they only ceased to manifest
themselves when the other
the great rat with the baleful eyes came
upon the scene
the reading lamp only was lit and its
green shade kept a ceiling in the upper
part of the room in darkness
so that the cheerful light from the
hearth spreading over the floor
and shining on the white cloth laid over
the end of the table
was warm and cheery malcolmson sat down
to his dinner with a good appetite
and a buoyant spirit after his dinner
and a cigarette he sat steadily down to
work
determined not to let anything disturb
him for he remembered his promise to the
doctor
and made up his mind to make the best of
the time at his disposal
for an hour or so he worked all right
and then his thoughts began to wander
from his books
the actual circumstances around him and
the calls on his physical attention
and his nervous susceptibility were not
to be denied
by this time the wind had become a gale
and the gale a storm
the old house solid though it was seemed
to shake to its foundation
and the storm roared and raged through
its many chimneys and its queer old
gables
producing strange unearthly sounds in
the empty rooms and corridors
even the great alarm bell on the roof
must have felt the force of the wind
for the rope rose and fell slightly as
though the bell were moved a little from
time to time
and the limber rope fell on the oak
floor with a hard and hollow
sound as malcolmson listened to it he
bethought himself of the doctor's words
it is the rope which the hangman used
for the victims of the judge's judicial
ranker
and he went over to the corner of the
fireplace and took it in his hand to
look at it
there seemed a sort of deadly interest
in it and as he stood there he lost
himself for a moment in speculation
as to who these victims were and the
grim wish of the judge to have such a
ghastly relic
ever under his eyes as he stood there
the swaying of the bell on the roof
still lifted the rope now and again
but presently there came a new sensation
a sort of tremor in the rope
as though something was moving along it
looking up instinctively malcolmson saw
the great rat coming slowly down towards
him
glaring at him steadily he dropped the
rope and started back with a muttered
curse
and the rat turning ran up the rope
again and disappeared
and at the same instant malcomson became
conscious that the noise of the other
rats which had ceased for a while
began again all this said him
thinking and it occurred to him that he
had not investigated the lair of the rat
or looked at the pictures
as he had intended he lit the other lamp
without the shade
and holding it up went and stood
opposite the third picture from the
fireplace
on the right-hand side where he had seen
the rat disappear on the previous night
at the first glance he started back so
suddenly that he almost dropped the lamp
and a deadly pallor overspread his face
his knees shook and heavy drops of sweat
came on his forehead
and he trembled like an aspen but he was
young and plucky and pulled himself
together
and after the pause of a few seconds
stepped forward again
raised the lamp and examined the picture
which had been dusted and washed
and now stood out clearly it was of a
judge
dressed in his robes of scarlet and
urman
his face was strong and merciless evil
crafty and vindictive with a sensual
mouth
hooked nose of ruddy color and shaped
like the beak of a bird of prey
the rest of the face was of a cadaverous
color
the eyes were of peculiar brilliance and
with a terribly malignant expression
as he looked at them malcolmson grew
cold for he saw there the very
counterpart of the eyes of the great rat
the lamp almost fell from his hand he
saw the rat with its baleful eyes
peering out through the hole in the
corner of the picture
and noted the sudden cessation of the
noise of the other rats
however he pulled himself together and
went on with his examination of the
picture
the judge was seated in a great
high-backed carved oak chair
on the right-hand side of a great stone
fireplace
where in the corner a rope hung down
from the ceiling
its end lying coiled on the floor with a
feeling of something like horror
malcolmson recognized the scene of the
room as it stood
and gazed around him in an awestruck
manner as though he expected to find
some strange presence behind him
then he looked over to the corner of the
fireplace and with a loud cry he let the
lamp fall from his hand
there in the judge's armchair with the
rope hanging behind
sat the rat with the judge's baleful
eyes now
intensified as with a fiendish lear
save for the howling of the storm
without there was silence
the fallen lamp recalled malcolmson to
himself
fortunately it was of metal and so the
oil was not spilled
however the practical need of attending
to it settled at once his nervous
apprehensions
when he had turned it out he wiped his
brow and thought for a moment
this will not do he said to himself if i
go on like this i shall become a crazy
fool
this must stop i promised the doctor i
would not take tea
faith he was pretty right my nerves must
have been getting into a queer state
funny i did not notice it i never felt
better in my life
however it's all right now and i shall
not be such a fool again
then he mixed himself a good stiff glass
of brandy and water
and resolutely sat down to his work
it was nearly an hour when he looked up
from his book disturbed by the sudden
stillness
without the wind howled and roared
louder than ever
and the rain drove in sheets against the
windows beating like hail on the glass
but within there was no sound whatever
saved the echo of the wind as it roared
in the great chimney
and now and then a hiss as a few
raindrops found their way down the
chimney in a lull of the storm
the fire had fallen low and it ceased to
flame though it threw out a red glow
malcolmson listened attentively and
presently heard a thin
squeaking noise very faint it came from
the corner of the room where the rope
hung down
and he thought it was the creaking of
the rope on the floor as the swaying of
the bell raised and lowered it
looking up however he saw on the dim
light the great rat clinging to the rope
and gnawing it
the rope was already nearly gnawed
through he could see the lighter color
where the strands were laid bare
as he looked the job was completed and
the severed end of the rope fell
clattering on the open floor
whilst for an instant the great rat
remained like a knob or tassel
at the end of the rope which now began
to sway to and fro
malcolmson felt for a moment another
pang of terror as he thought that now
the possibility of calling the outer
world to his assistance was cut off
but an intense anger took its place and
seizing the book he was reading he
hurled it at the rat
the blow was well aimed but before the
missile could reach him the rat dropped
off
and struck the floor with a soft thud
malcomson instantly rushed over towards
him but it darted away and disappeared
in the darkness of the shadows of the
room
malcolmson felt that his work was over
for the night and determined then and
there to vary the monotony of the
proceedings by a hunt for the rat
and took off the green shade of the lamp
so as to ensure a wider spreading light
as he did so the gloom of the upper part
of the room was relieved
and in the new flood of light great by
comparison with the previous darkness
the pictures on the wall stood out
boldly
from where he stood malcolmson saw right
opposite to him the third picture on the
wall from the right of the fireplace
he rubbed his eyes in surprise and then
a great fear began to come upon him
in the center of the picture was a great
irregular patch of brown canvas
as fresh as when it was stretched on the
frame the background was as before
with chair and chimney corner and rope
but the figure of the judge
had disappeared malcomson almost in a
chill of horror
turned slowly round and then he began to
shake and tremble like a man in a palsy
his strength seemed to have left him and
he was incapable of action or movement
hardly even of thought he could only see
and hear
there on the great high-backed carved
oak chair sat the judge
in his robes of scarlet and ermine with
his baleful eyes glaring vindictively
and a smile of triumph on the resolute
cruel mouth
as he lifted with his hands a black cap
malcolmson felt as if the blood was
running from his heart
as one does in moments of prolonged
suspense
there was a singing in his ears without
he could hear the roar and howl of the
tempest
and through it swept on the storm came
the striking of midnight by the great
chimes in the marketplace
he stood for a space of time that seemed
to him endless
still as a statue and with wide open
horror struck eyes
breathless as the clock struck so the
smile of triumph on the judge's face
intensified
and at the last stroke of midnight he
placed the black cap on his head
slowly and deliberately the judge rose
from his chair and picked up the piece
of rope of the alarm bell which lay on
the floor
drew it through his hands as if he
enjoyed its touch and then deliberately
began to knot one end of it
fashioning it into a noose this he
tightened and tested with his foot
pulling hard at it till he was satisfied
and then making a running noose of it
which he held in his hand
then he began to move along the table on
the opposite side of malcomson
keeping his eyes on him until he had
passed him when with a quick movement he
stood in front of the door
malcolmson then began to feel that he
was trapped and tried to think of what
he should do
there was some fascination in the
judge's eyes which he never took off him
and he had perforce to look he saw the
judge approach
still keeping between him and the door
and raised the noose and throw it
towards him
as if to entangle him with a great
effort he made a quick movement to one
side
and saw the rope fall beside him and
heard it strike the open floor
again the judge raised the noose and
tried to ensnare him
ever keeping his baleful eyes fixed on
him and each time by a mighty effort the
student just managed to evade it
so this went on for many times the judge
seeming never discouraged nor
discomposed at failure
but playing as a cat does with a mouse
at last in despair which had reached its
climax malcolmson cast a quick glance
around him
the lamp seemed to have blazed up and
there was a fairly good light in the
room
at the many rat holes and in the chinks
and crannies of the wainscot he saw the
rat's eyes
and this aspect that was purely physical
gave him a gleam of comfort
he looked round and saw that the rope of
the great alarm bell was laden with rats
every inch of it was covered with them
and more and more were pouring through
the small circular hole in the ceiling
once it emerged
so that with their weight the bell was
beginning to sway
hark it had swayed till the clapper had
touched the bell
the sound was but a tiny one but the
bell was only beginning to sway
and it would increase at the sound the
judge who had been keeping his eyes
fixed on malcolmson
looked up and a scowl of diabolical
anger overspread his face
his eyes fairly glowed like hot coals
and he stamped his foot with a sound
that seemed to make the house shake
a dreadful peel of thunder broke
overhead as he raised the rope again
whilst the rats kept running up and down
the rope as though working against time
this time instead of throwing it he drew
close to his victim
and held open the noose as he approached
as he came
closer there seemed something paralyzing
in his very presence
and malcolmson stood rigid as a corpse
he felt the judge's icy fingers touch
his throat as he adjusted the rope
the noose tightened tightened then the
judge
taking the rigid form of the student in
his arms carried him over and placed him
standing in the oak chair
and stepping up beside him put his hand
up and caught the end of the swaying
rope of the alarm bell
as he raised his hand the rats fled
squeaking and disappeared through the
hole in the ceiling
taking the end of the noose which was
round malcolmson's neck
he tied it to the hanging bell rope and
then descending
pulled away the chair when the alarm
bell of the judge's house began to sound
a crowd soon assembled lights and
torches of various kinds appeared
and soon a silent crowd was hurrying to
the spot
they knocked loudly at the door but
there was no reply
then they burst in the door and poured
into the great dining room
the doctor at the head there at the end
of the rope of the great alarm bell
hung the body of the student and on the
face of the judge in the picture was a
malignant smile
you